لم تستانف الدراسه في اول ايامها بعد
اجازه منتصف العام
بقيت ابواب المدارس موصده وغاب التلاميذ
والمعلمون الذين يواصلون اضرابا عن العمل
لتحقيق مطالبهم
من اجل النظام لا من اين
سنه البيئه بتاعه المدرسه يتحسن وضع
المعلم عشان نكون في وضع شنو ممتاز وضعي
جيد هل يعقل انه يكون الاستاذ
القسيمه الزواج ليه اقل من دولارين هل
يعقل انه يكون الاستاذ بدل الوجبه بتاعه
اقل من خمسه دولار الكلام ده يعني لا يعقل
بالحقيقه يعني لم يقتصر ضربه على العاصمه
بل شمل عددا من ولايات السودان الاخرى
الاضرابات شملت ايضا قطعيا الصحه والتعليم
الجامعي حيث وصل التعبير عن الغضب الى
الشارع
هؤلاء اساتذه الجامعات بعد اضراب لهم عن
العمل دخل اسبوع الثالث رئاسه الوزراء
يوجهتهم ومطلبهم رفع الاجور خصوصا ان
متوسطه دخل الاستاذ الجامعي لا يزيد على
400 و50 دولارا
الغرض من هذا الاضراب واجازه هيكل الهيكل
الراتب لعام 23 المستند على لائحه شروط
شروط الخدمه التي اجازها المجلس القومي
للتعليم العالي مؤخرا
غير بعيد من هذا المكان احتجل عاملون في
وزاره الصحه المطالب ذاتها رفعت هنا قبل
اضافه الى رفع الاجور طالب المحتجون برفع
كفاءه العاملين في القطاع الصحي
[تصفيق]
مسؤولون حكوميون التقوا بالمعلمين ولجنه
اساتذه الجامعات واعلن التزامهم بتنفيذ
مطالبهم لكنهم تحفظوا عن رفع الحد الادنى
للاجور المعلمين البالغ 20 دولار الطائره
المرضي الجزيره الخرطوم